les autres sont avec leurs familles nous
on n'en a pas on n'a pas le droit de
sortir comme ça les pions déserté ils
s'en foutent noël l'entrée sur l'île de
l'océan est interdit pour le moment
accès impossible
ces morts ici venez
j ils ont laissé tout cash qu'est ce que
tu fous et oh ça va
quoi message d'extrême urgence
veuillez ne pas quitter vos données qui
laurie dix mois ce qui s'est passé père
a tué ma soeur laure et ça on va tous
mourir
on est peut-être affecté aussi même pas
si ça dépendait pas de l'âge qu'on a
mais plutôt des expériences qu'on a vécu
les gars me suis pas comme eux j'ai même
pas encore 18 ans fausse tirer d'ici
lord comment
maintenant c'est chacun pour sa gueule
mais qu'est ce que c'est
ce michel